I'm Roman metal from wool research and
today I will present on counting
socketable crimes that something that
started as a discussion on the ocean
community which they made it up a
several months worth of computing and
they still move to be done so this is a
progressive
so this go out of community post well
from community and there were two people
Sando Sando marker who contributed to
that discussion and it went on for quite
a while and then I started to actually
do a little bit of more more
computations in this particular field so
what is the reason for doing this so the
reason is that there was some
numberphile video where they displayed
this particular pencil you can actually
buy those and this is a prime number
that you see here and when you sharpen
the pencil eventually the bit will chop
off that first digit right when the
pencil gets shorter and shorter
and what you then see what remains is
another prime number and so on until the
very end to that seven down here which
is also prime number so all of these
truncations from the left are primes and
this happens to be the longest one k
double prime in base 10 so here is that
computation which verifies that claim so
I start with that number I truncate it
from the left and then eventually just
we do that and just apply prime Q to all
of these and they should all be two so
question now how many such crimes are
there and how long are the longest ones
and what about other bases ten ten and
four smaller bases where there aren't
that many Prime's you can actually store
all of those now it doesn't really make
a lot of sense to store all of those
because most of these are truncations of
other ones were assuming they are called
two uncharitable Prime's for a reason so
there are some maximal ones which cannot
be extended so you can think of it as a
form of three and eventually
use of the 3ds are the maximals and if
you cut off branches from the bottom
then you get all the other two on K
double prime so I was also interested in
not only all the trunk a table perhaps
but also all the maximal ones and how do
you search for these while you start
from the ground up you start with the
zero or one digit primes and then you
have all the digits from one to base
minus one so there are B minus one
digits and to go from k to k plus one
you just look at all the candidates just
have one of the kdg Prime's first digit
is 1 then digit 2 up to P minus 1 and
there are B minus 1 such numbers and
then you just test them for primality
that is quite fast and I mean I once
wrote the original version of their
parent test over in 20 or 25 years ago
their since been improved and so this is
quite fast and if none of these
extensions are prime then P itself is a
maximal two on k double prime otherwise
it's not maximal and we continue to
search with all the prime candidates and
there are two natural ways of doing the
search breadth-first so going from k
equals 1 k equals to k 3 and so on
depth-first recursive search so you
always go down the left-most branch of
the tree and these are useful for
different situations if you want to
generate all of them or parallelized
research then breadth-first search is
the way to go if you just want to find
out how many there are
then you can do a depth first search the
advantage of the depth-first search it
doesn't require any intermediate memory
other than other than the stack and we
will see that there are quite alone
large number of these Prime's
so here's an outline of a very simple
procedure for doing a recursive search
so I start recursive search all Prime's
for a given base I have some global
variables for the
kind of results I'm interested in the
length distribution so how many crimes
of lengths one two three four and so on
and what are the longest ones so these
are the kind of global high watermark
variables and here's my recursive search
procedure and all the the magic hack
happens inside these statements so
digits is a list of all the digits
multiplied by beta and at P that gives
me the B minus one candidates are
testing for parity and if there are no
new crimes then this one is maximal and
so I update the global variables and if
there are any then I here is the
recursive call of that procedure to all
the new candidates and I start with the
initial prime zero I do not count it
because it's not real prime but it can
be used to start the search and I will
return the results nowadays don't spend
time explaining my coat but I should
let's see let's we do it here and so
what you get the still result is the
number of leaf climbs for base ten total
number of Tuncay double Prime's the
longest length the longest length the
list of primes of that lengths there
happens to be just one and here R is the
length distribution of the leaf primes
and here is the length distribution of
all Prime's so you can see there are
obviously for one digit Prime's
and two of those are leaf Prime's
because with two and five these are not
co-prime with the base so they die out
there is no other primes that end in two
or five except two and five the other
two one digit Prime's
give rise to eleven two digit Prime's
all of those can be extended there are
39 3 digit Prime's one of those is
maximal the other ones go on and so on
so this is the kind of result that I'm
interested here in space 16 they are
quite a bit more primes in base 16 I did
somehow didn't evaluate the
initialization cells now I have no menu
here well okay let me okay I did pre
compute it so it should still should
still work here so so this is the
longest Prime in base 16 it's just a
little bit longer but there are quite a
bit more crimes here in base 19 there
are very few just 685 but there are 4
longest ones and you can see that that's
very typical that two of those have the
same the same branch right and just a
lot the initial digit which is different
here and another one is also part of
that branch and then there is a fourth
one that happened along the way but the
striking thing which if you look at that
discussion in the motion community you
can see why is there such a big
difference in the number of times for
different bases and so I started to
think about really attacking larger
bases where there are a lot more Prime's
and so I obviously have to do it in
parallel so I found the best method to
do is to just start a tab let's first
search say for the first four four links
1 2 3 4 that gives me a number of
candidates and then I do a depth first
search for each of those and they are
completely independent and the jobs to
check pointing and so all that which is
necessary because some of these jobs 1 4
months or even years so we need all of
these techniques for organizing large
jobs and what I wanted to do is exactly
what I showed before I want to note
enough number of Tanqueray to prime
spoken done balance the maximal length
and all the longest ones and I always
worked with integers and not digit
strings it's never necessary to come
actually convert to base B only when I
want to see the result in a nice form
so we then found that these numbers of
truncated Prime's for various bases is
already
already an entry in the online
encyclopedia of integer sequences okay
so that's a mouthful to say and so we
looked at that and there was the one
case that was missing was base 24 and so
want to know how long does it take to
compute it and with four digits there
are just 3808 Prime's so that's a good
number to start these parallel jobs
because I want the parallel jobs need to
have a certain one time they shouldn't
be trivial otherwise there is too much
communication with the master kernel but
I don't want any individual jobs to run
for days because I'm interested in
intermediate results and see how it
progresses so here it was just two
minutes on average this is the one time
distribution at the total sequential one
time was just 127 hours which means that
on a machine was 22 processors it's an
overnight job just six hours of
computing time so what are the results
in base 24 there is just over 1 billion
to inaudible crimes the maximum length
is 53 there are two maximum crimes of
length 53 here they are in base 24 and
so that and if you want it to store them
it will actually be feasible it's just 8
gigabytes of memory needed to store them
as base B strings if you wanted to do
that so that was encouraging to see that
this computation which apparently has
never been done before because that
entry was missing in the in that
encyclopedia that was entirely feasible
and so we wanted to look at some of the
more of the more challenging bases so
actually here is an interesting graphic
coming out of this result because I have
for each length I have the number of
leaf primes and non leaf primes
so if you look at one particular length
here then you see
the high th the total number of crimes
of that length and the yellow ones are
the extensible ones which are the seed
for the next k plus one and the blue
ones are those that die out that are
maximal and as we will see the
probabilities of these numbers being
prime will slowly decrease and so after
this grows it will slowly die out and
eventually at 53
there is just one left that will is
maximal and so the computation stops now
the big question was why are there are
so big differences in the number of
primes for different bases
and this is actually quite elementary
number theory these candidates that we
search a plus B a plus 2 B up to a plus
B minus 1 form an arithmetic progression
and there is a theorem about the number
of primes in an arithmetic progression
which is 2 whenever the increment and
the starting value are co-prime which is
2 in our case for large enough K and so
this theorem applies and there was all
even there is some prior work about 20 a
double Prime's which I found in 1977
that was already considered at that
point so this formula should give me an
idea of how many Prime's to expect and
here it is now four paces from one to a
hundred so I just chose one arbitrary K
20 and here is the are the values for
the for this formula and you can see
that the value 24 which is here which
was obviously the most difficult one of
those before it but then there's this
length 30 which seems to be quite hard
and then 42 and so on for
before sixty and ninety so why is it
where does this distribution come for
and before I answer that question I want
to be sure to show you that this
actually agrees very well with the
results so here is the same blue points
but I also have yellow points these are
the actual results from the computations
so you can see here twenty four is that
result here the largest one I've done is
eighty five up here the next one that
could be doable is forty and thirty as
we will see requires a little bit more
computing infrastructure so the
correspondence between the theoretical
results and the measurements is quite
good so here is the reason that this
happens for different places now one of
the terms in that equation was the euler
totient function of P to the K and there
are many ways to write that function but
the most convenient for this particular
application is in this form it's P to
the K times the product of 1 by minus 1
over P I where P I runs over all these
stinked prime factors of B and so if a
number has many distinct small prime
factors it will have more Prime's
and so even bases have more times than
odd ones because the smallest prime
possible is 2 so 1 minus 1 over 2 that
cuts off quite a bit more than any other
prime and the next one to consider is 2
times 3 or 2 times 3 times 5 that is
certain that is the reason why that case
30 is so difficult and the next
difficult one would be 42 which is 2
times 3 times 7 and indeed 30 is the
smallest base for which we do not yet
know how many of the
- okay - with bronze there are so here
then is a big table of the results that
we have done so far you can see that
there is 29 and 31 so 30 is missing but
everything before is there there are
some many cases where I didn't even have
to paralyze so you see here there is one
just one job I don't know how to make
this table bigger I don't know whether
we can read it but here's some some
cases I did parallel eyes this is the
total one time which is not very exact
because I use different machines so it's
not necessarily comparable then here's
the number of primes leaf times total
Prime's
long the maximum lengths and the list of
those Prime's of maximal length so you
see base 18 has quite a large number of
primes and 24 of course is the record
holder so far then if we go on then we
see there is the biggest one I've done
which took me more than a month on that
22 core machine 93 billion primes there
are some big ones here 37 billion for
base 44 and 30 billion for base 46 and
the longest is 65 here for base 46 there
there's a problem with 65 digits in base
46 so what we now will do eventually is
to update try to update those entries in
the online encyclopedia of integer
sequences because they contains quite a
few fewer results than I have here now
there's the disclaimer I have to make to
make prime Q is a probabilistic prime
test so these numbers are strictly
speaking upper bounds but I did take all
the longest ones that you can see here
and subjected to a deterministic but
probably a prime ality test and also
there
it's truncation so all the numbers that
here are guaranteed to be prime so
here's my wish list I then took thee
from the theory the expected complexity
this is a log this is an exponential
measure so even though these numbers are
closely together they are quite if you
can see here the value 30 is you will
see in a minute how long it will take
then there is the value 60 down here
which is the next more difficult one
which we will see is completely
impossible within the lifetime of the
universe so this is quite a bit big
increase in the complexity now there are
cases that will eventually also be
doable like 42 here for the 40 is here
that's actually the the next one to
attack after 30 and so on so this is the
kind of wish list but what does it take
to actually solve or make progress on
this wish list here is my estimate for
how long it will take for base 30 so I
did I just started with some random
sample of these Prime's and let it run
for for about a month or so just to see
get the feel of what what is involved
and then I did an extrapolation so I
would expect there to be about 23 twill
Ian of these primes and the computation
should take about 750 single-core years
so if I want to have a one month project
I would need 10,000 CPU calls and if
there's anyone in here who is sitting on
unused machine with 10,000 cores and
please let me know I mean there are some
companies there some businesses in on
this planet that are big enough that we
will tap for and ask for help there's
some obvious obvious choices here and
then the next month's to attack are
these I mean eventually to install
being useful because it was just the
computation time we just grow much to
very large values I mean if you're
talking about millions of years oh and
that that's no longer worthwhile so
there are better things to do with your
idle CPU course but 30 would be nice to
the tackle and a sixty is hopeless I've
haven't even been able to derive an
estimate because everyone however deep I
went with the initial search each one of
those we recursive searches never never
finished all I know is that the length
is at least 92 and that should give you
an idea if you compare it with a kind of
50 or 60 that we have with the other
cases that this will just take longer
than the the lifetime of the universe
probably and I feel obliged to end with
a picture of pumpkins because of
Halloween celebrity celebrations today
and also because this is quite a bit
spooky there
the CDs these these large values that we
know outside of our reach and that's the
end of my presentation thank you okay
questions
I mean I'm using the prime Q function of
Mathematica for all of these of all the
prime ality tests so it's it's a
standard parallel computing parallel
mathematical computation I have a master
colonel that distributes those Prime's
and then there are all the slave girl
instead to the jobs and when they are
done it's written to disk as a
checkpointing measure and then it does
the next one and that just once on my
machine all at a low priority no I
haven't I mean III personally I've never
used GPUs for anything like that
and I'm not aware of other any parity
test packages for GPUs I don't know I
don't know how much that that will that
will give it's not that kind of GPUs are
good when you have the same thing to do
for multiple eight about here each each
prime test once completely differently
why did it has the the middle of our
beam test and all of these things maybe
there is something like that but I don't
know yes
well I think there are no known counter
examples to that primarily tests that we
use I actually don't know exactly what
the contest is but there is this is a
standard but standard procedure there
are two tests mellow a beam and another
one and if you combine those then we
know pretty much that I mean there is no
yeah no no no known cases where it
doesn't work so it's and here especially
if we do it you know with these two
equations then the chances that such a
sequence will all be wrong is quite low
no I mean the longest the longest one we
have encountered is sixty-five digits to
base 40 which translates to how many
digits to base 10 look I mean not not
that much now I mean I mean the the
deterministic test at the end was was
quite a challenge I mean there's a
package in Mathematica for the provable
point Q which gives you a certificate
it's it's a clever bit of class field
theory to derive at the computation that
proves that a certain number is prime
now that code is over 20 years old and
there are flow flows of control in that
code which have a parent he never been
exercised because they didn't work so I
first had to debug that package before I
could use it for this particular now the
package will be replaced by something
there will be some new number theory
functions in future versions of
Mathematica but once I I solved that
problem it was actually quite feasible
within a few minutes for each of those
maximal problems to test them exactly
for primality without any doubt